et pour en parler on retrouve notre
invité étienne combier les rédacteurs en
chef de nova stan un média spécialisé
sur l'asie centrale bonjour à vous merci
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france on l'apprend ce matin pour
justin lin ancien chef de la sécurité
qui a été arrêté pour trahison il s'agit
de karim massimov un proche injustement
de l'ex président noursoultan nazarbaïev
est ce qu'il ya une tentative selon vous
déstabilisation à l'intérieur même des
serres du pouvoir au kazakhstan
écoutez c'est assez compliqué à le dire
aujourd'hui on a vraiment une situation
qui est très différente aujourd'hui
entre almaty et le reste du pays alors
effectivement vous l'avez mentionné
l'arrestation de karim massimov montre
qu' il ya une détermination de
l'administration tokayev a essayé de
trouver des coupables a des
répercussions ou en tout cas des
manifestations très violentes à almaty
la capitale économique pour autant
aujourd'hui on a du mal à faire
exactement le le comme on dit à la
distinction entre les affirmations du
président et la réalité à savoir
effectivement une situation qui
s'envenime très très rapidement à almaty
le 5 janvier alors qu'auparavant entre
le 2 et le 5 janvier on a une manie des
manifestations certes importante mais
qui ne sont pas aussi violente et
aujourd'hui donc un comme vous
l'expliqué dans le sujet une situation
qui est relativement calme dans le dans
le pays mais encore une fois on retrouve
cette distinction entre la capitale
économique et les autres villes on a
d'ailleurs d'autres manifestations qui
sont encore en cours de manière
pacifique à jana ozenne et dans d'autres
villes actuellement au kazakhstan alors
des situations distinctes un vous le
dites dans les villes du kazakhstan qui
sont les manifestants
les manifestants sont principalement des
casaques
a cédé du de commentaires du commando au
kazakhstan a été gérée depuis des années
on a aujourd'hui des une politique qui
est à peu près la même depuis des années
de peu importe le changement de
président donc de casting jomart tokayev
qui arrivait en juin 2019 en
remplacement donc noursoultan nazarbaïev
on est dans une situation la quotidien
des casaques
avec une augmentation du prix
de l'alimentation le paiement de plus de
10% on a un an
donc on a la foi des casaques très très
très
con dire remonté contre un gouvernement
qui n'a pas suffisamment redistribuer
les richesses produites par le
kazakhstan qui est quand même
extrêmement riche en hydrocarbures
auront 10 radio mais ainsi et de l'autre
on a aussi vu effectivement quelques
éléments qui ont été très violents géant
à almaty mais je pense que c'est
vraiment pas la majorité
un mouvement assez assez pacifique en
général alors vous dites un mouvement
pacifique en général et pourtant on a
entendu donc le président du kazakhstan
autoriser les tirs à balles réelles sur
les manifestants refusaient aussi le
dialogue
c'est ça signifie quoi concrètement sur
la suite du mouvement il ya une volonté
de réprimer ce mouvement
écoutez oui effectivement les mots du
président kazakh qui ont été extrêmement
durs ils ont il a quand même estimé que
les manifestants étaient des terroristes
des bandits des meurtriers ainsi de
suite c'est objectivement pas d'aidé des
mots comme on dira qu'ils amènent à une
négociation politique simple pour autant
malgré l'ordre de tirer sans sommation
qui a été donnée hier dans la journée
donc on n'a pas eu effectivement des
deux massacres au conte aurait
heureusement qu'on dira on a on était
inquiet que des massacres se puisse se
produire ils ne se sont pas produits
donc on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation d'attenté où on a un mouvement
donc en dehors d'allemagne demande
encore la démission du chef qui
demandent des changements de politiques
et qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
entendu tout à fait en tout cas les
gosses ne sont pas ouvertes avec des zac
après est ce que cette situation évolue
dans les prochains jours le noyau dur de
la manifestation on lui dit c'est ta al
mahdi almaty
pour quelles raisons
c'est une visa soit oui alors déjà c'est
la plus grande ville du pays d'oc
capitale économique c'est elle qui était
capital avant que astana ne le soit dans
à la fin des années 90 c'est clairement
là où les intérêts politiques et
économiques sont les plus importants
pour autant là on n'a pas une zone
vraiment de flou sur justement à quel
moment les manifestations sont
radicalisées ont pris une autre ampleur
à almaty le gouvernement kazakh estime
que ce tome mouvement anti-ivg de
l'étranger d'organisation mais c'est pas
forcément ça conserve quand on y regarde
de plus près en attendant c'est
factuellement que les les manifestations
extrêmement dégénéré d'antan dans cette
ville donc on ne sait pas à quel point
et ça a été organisé où ça a été lancé
par
telle ou telle personne au kazakhstan et
peut-être de l'étranger entendre aussi
le président du kazakhstan
ça je pense que objectivement ce n'est
pas pas très crédible on s'est souvent
une rhétorique dans des gouvernements
central et est située à quand des
révoltes ont lieu en interne d'aller
blâmer l'étranger
objectivement l'opposition kazakhe est
inaudible ou en tout cas beaucoup trop
faible pour à organiser ce genre de
violence et de
taxation donc ça me paraît assez
improbable alors le kazakhstan qui a
fait appel à l'hôtel c'est
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective
donc des troupes une des forces de
maintien de la paix russes
en provenance de russie et de ses alliés
mènent des opérations est ce que ça va
participer justement apaiser la
situation au kazakhstan
alors déjà on peut le dire les troupes
de l'hôtel sont uniquement mobilisés à
almaty donc ça va dans le sens de ce que
je vous disais à propos du fait que on
avait donc deux types vraiment de
d'événements almaty et le reste du pays
pour autant ce donc ses troupes donc
près de 2500 militaires dont 2000 russes
sont effectivement là pour protéger les
et les bâtiments
essentiel de de l'état kazakh après de
là à voir s'il y aura un vrai vraie
différence je ne suis pas sûr encore une
fois on a on a en termes de nombre on
est quand même assez limité par rapport
à l'ensemble du nombre de forces de
police et de militaires kazakhs déployés
dans le pays après ça a surtout un
impact symbolique
2e pour le gouvernement kazakh de
montrer qu'ils sont soutenus par par ses
alliés sur le concrètement sur le
terrain je pense que le kazakhstan reste
tu as fait en mesure de contrôler la
situation mais mais ce ne sera pas
forcément nous 2500 militaires étrangers
qui vous faire pencher la balance merci
beaucoup à vos etienne mon billet je
rappelle que vous êtes rédacteur en chef
a de nouveau astana médias
spécialisés
sur l'asie centrale merci